E aí
oi oi
hoje eu acordei com uma manhã qualquer
com uma vontade imensa de viver parece
que algo dentro de mim uma chave havia
virado e eu comecei a perceber com
valiosa era a vida então eu olhei para
pessoa que estava do meu lado a minha
esposa e simplesmente eu agradeci olhei
para o meu quarto as coisas que tinha e
aquele me trouxe uma felicidade imensa
quando eu saí abri a porta do meu quarto
e fui ao quarto do meu filho e percebi
que ele estava dormindo calmamente com
saúde em paz eu me tornei uma pessoa
ainda mais grata e fui observando cada
coisa que eu tinha e cheguei na cozinha
e vi um café pronto para que eu pudesse
comer para que eu pudesse de tomar e
aquilo me trouxe uma alegria imensa
eu acabei de tomar aquele café ou estava
pronto mas pronto para que pronto para o
meu dia e quem sabe o meu último dia
essa reflexão eu comecei eu comecei a
escrever um livro e se fosse o seu
último dia e se fosse a sua última
oportunidade de fazer alguma coisa esse
hoje você que está aí nos assistindo
fosse a última oportunidade de você está
assistindo um ted a última oportunidade
de você está participando de um evento
como você faria você daria mais
intensidade eu estaria mais intenso
prestando mais atenção e é a reflexão
ela não acaba apenas aí esse fosse o seu
último dia no trabalho o seu último dia
com a sua família o seu último dia com
as pessoas que você ama como você faria
de que forma você faria o seu último
abraço o seu último beijo a sua última
refeição ouça
o momento com as pessoas que você disse
que ama com as pessoas que você importa
e essa reflexão eu faço porque se nós
conversar se começarmos a olhar dessa
maneira E se fosse nosso último dia quem
sabe algumas pessoas olhariam para trás
e diria Poxa eu vivi uma boa vida é
acabei a combati O Bom Combate acabei a
carreira e guardei a fé como Paulo fala
eu vivi uma boa vida ou você olharia
para trás e de Ah poxa Quantas coisas eu
poderia estar fazendo poderia ter feito
e não fiz Quantas coisas eu não não
precisaria ter feito e eu fiz quantas
pessoas é uma magoei e que eu não
precisaria ter magoado Quantas coisas
Quantas coisas mas parece que nosso
último dia essa percepção vem na gente
parece que nosso último dia a gente
começa a perceber essas coisas e por que
isso acontece porque no nosso último dia
nós somos
e é acometidos de uma sabedoria que nós
não temos e que eu chamo da sabedoria da
sombra da morte você percebeu que
algumas pessoas aqui tiveram experiência
de quase-morte experiências que eu
também já tive e parece que tudo aquilo
não valeu a pena e a gente poderia viver
de uma maneira diferente de uma maneira
mais intensa sendo pessoas mais grata as
pessoas mais felizes não se importando
tanto com o que os outros pensariam
sobre nós poderemos viver melhor e essa
sabedoria ela vem quando a gente está
perto do fim da nossa vida só que o
problema que nenhum de nós ou a maioria
de Nossa não sabe quando vai ser o nosso
último dia a maioria de nós não sabe
quando vai ser aí e que bom que não
sabemos porque talvez não viveríamos da
maneira que deveríamos viver mas se
fosse o meu último dia hoje eu faria
coisas diferente porque a sombra da
morte ou quando estamos chegando
e da Morte ela nos ensina a coisas
extraordinária e que paradoxo não é a
morte nos ensina sobre a vida a morte
nos ensina como viver e a minha avó me
ensinou isso porque um período da minha
vida eu vivi com a minha avó existe uma
pessoa que ia toda a noite na casa da
minha avó a minha avó dava janta para
ele e ele ia embora só que eu nunca
entendi porque eu sempre achei aquela
pessoa uma no sentido literal da palavra
folgada poxa vem Come e vai embora mas é
minha avó sempre dizia Poxa Ivan mas se
eu posso dar porque eu não não vou dar
mas hoje eu entendo que a minha vó ela
estava com sabedoria e que me faltava a
sabedoria e ela tinha essa sabedoria da
sombra da morte esse hoje
e esse hoje nós conseguimos desenvolver
essa sabedoria se hoje a gente
aprendesse a viver da maneira que
realmente deveríamos viver se hoje a
gente aprendesse a valorizar as pessoas
como nós deveríamos valorizar Porque as
pessoas não são eternas do nosso lado
quantas pessoas ou quantos velórios Você
já foi em que as pessoas falavam tantos
elogios tantas coisas boas para aquela
pessoa que já não poderia mais ouvir
talvez e quantas vezes quantas
oportunidades a gente poderia ter falado
isso vivido isso abraçado aquelas
pessoas e quando eu falo assim ei pode
ser o seu último dia algumas pessoas dão
risada algumas pessoas fazem piada e
algumas pessoas falam assim baixaram
boca menina você não sabe nem que que
você está falando Mas de fato pode ser o
seu último dia quem é que pode me
afirmar de sem por cento de certeza que
amanhã está vivo
e eu não sei eu não tenho certeza pode
acontecer qualquer coisa a gente pode
não estar vivo e talvez um Aproveitou a
oportunidade de fazer algo tão majestoso
tão glorioso como viver como abraçar
como beijar como é viver intensamente
cada momento que realmente pode ser pode
ser o nosso último dia porque no dia em
24 horas aproximadamente no mundo morre
150 mil pessoas e durante a minha
apresentação aproximadamente morreram
duas mil pessoas no mundo
Essa é a gente não quer falar sobre isso
mas é necessário eu espero sinceramente
que não seja você mas se for Espero que
você aproveite muito esse evento E se
fosse meu último dia do trabalho e por
que que eu coloquei isso e vamos porque
que você colocou isso porque algumas
pessoas quando eu fiz uma pesquisa nas
redes sociais falava para mim assim ah
se fosse meu último dia eu nem ia
trabalhar e talvez você que está
assistindo responderia isso também que
não iria trabalhar mas deixa eu te
perguntar o trabalho também não é vida
estava lá no trabalho também não é vida
está talvez fazendo algumas coisas que
que às vezes você talvez não goste
também não é viver será que a gente vai
viver somente os finais de semana
Olá tudo é vida e como eu realizaria o
meu trabalho se fosse a minha última
oportunidade eu daria o meu melhor eu me
entregaria ao máximo eu queria assim
deixar um buraco na vida das pessoas
quer dizer se Poxa como o Ivan faz falta
aqui como seria bom ter ele aqui ou seja
se fosse meu último dia de trabalho eu
ia querer deixar assim o meu legado e
pode ser o meu último dia de trabalho
pode ser a última oportunidade que eu
estou me apresentando no tédio ou vendo
um Ted o falando com você e talvez seja
a última oportunidade que você tenha de
ver um ted e quantas pessoas
apresentaram aqui jogar o ideias jogaram
sementes para você agora cabe a gente
pegar essas idéias colocar no bolso ou a
gente já aproveitar os nossos dias e foi
me perguntando o que eu faria se fosse
meu último dia e me pergunta aí o que eu
faria para humanidade se fosse o meu
último dia o que faria para as pessoas
existe um
o que disse que Quem planta tâmaras não
colhe tâmaras ou seja existe algumas
coisas que eu vou fazer e que talvez eu
não vou comer existe algumas sementes
que eu vou lançar que talvez eu nunca vi
nunca vou ver o fruto mas não importa o
importa que eu estou fazendo para a
humanidade pequenas coisas que a gente
pode fazer o nosso dia a dia que pode
impactar Uma Geração toda todinha aí
vamos mais eu não tenho grandes coisas
como por exemplo muitos milionários que
dão toda a sua fortuna no final da sua
vida eu não tenho uma fortuna talvez
você não tenha bom romenos eu não tenho
mas eu tenho algo que talvez muitas
pessoas precisam que é um abraço um
ombro amigo um ouvido para escutar
aquele que precisa
Oi hoje talvez não seja o seu último dia
mas Viva como se fosse e se entregue
para as pessoas também se importe com as
pessoas também que estão ao seu lado
intensidade seja intenso com as pessoas
que estão com você aí talvez é o
supra-sumo daquilo que eu sempre falei
sobre o último dia como eu viveria com
os meus amados e como você viveria com
seus amados talvez você está aí na sala
da sua casa e você está assistindo com
algumas pessoas que você ama ou que a
menos da boca para fora mas falamos
todos os dias que amamos filhos pais
amigos e a gente disse que ama mas às
vezes a gente não fala aí vão mais o
Fulano sabe que eu amo ele a plana sabe
que eu amo ela o meu pai sabe que eu amo
mais porque que você não fala
e o que que você não chega aliás eu teve
uma experiência ao escrever esse livro
porque o enviei várias mensagens de
áudio para algumas pessoas e falei assim
mano você é muito importante para mim
envia para o meu pai para minha mãe e
falei assim eu sou muito grato por tudo
que você fez por mim por quê Porque eu
estava com essa convicção que se fosse
meu último dia eu gostaria de falar isso
para o meu pai para minha mãe meu pai e
ele não chorou porque ele é um pouco
mais fechado mas a minha mãe chorou e
ela falou assim Ivan essa foi uma das
coisas mais bonitas que eu ouvi e tudo
partiu de um princípio de eu
simplesmente fazer as coisas como se eu
não tivesse uma outra oportunidade e
essa é a convicção que precisamos ter
talvez nós vamos ter uma outra
oportunidade de abraçar a pessoa que a
gente ama de beijar a pessoa que a gente
ama de estar perto das pessoas que a
gente ama
e não dia que ele abraça apertado que é
tão demorado aliás desse abraço desse
abraço apertado demorado não seja não
faça tão depressa isso faça como se
fosse uma despedida quantas vezes nós
saímos da Nossa Casa dos nossos lares e
não nos despedimos as pessoas que estão
lá como se elas estivessem lá para
sempre mas um dia você vai sair do
trabalho Talvez a pessoa não vai estar
lá Talvez um dia você vai sair para o
trabalho e você pode ser que não volte e
você viveu realmente o que você queria
viver Porque existe uma diferença e
novamente e viver e sobreviver
sobreviver é apenas existir e viver a
está intenso em cada momento
e eu não faria inimigos Com certeza se
fosse meu último dia eu talvez pediria
perdão para muitas pessoas mas eu jamais
faria inimigo sabe por quê Porque eu
descobria eu descobri que não vale a
pena de fato não vale a pena fazer
inimigos ou brigar com pessoas então uma
vez que eu postei uma coisa nas redes
sociais e algumas pessoas vieram me
criticar e eu peguei já te mandei um
áudio de 3 minutos para essa pessoa
falando das minhas razões daquilo que eu
achava sobre aquilo e depois eu peguei e
deletei como muitos de nós fazemos às
vezes por quê Porque eu descobri que não
vale a pena o que quer mais importante
uma frase ou um amigo eu coloquei na
balança e descobri que vale muito mais
um amigo a vida é como um clique e ela
está passando Como clicar o rápido algo
ligeiro a vida está passando e existe
até um filme que se chama clique que é
uma pessoa que estava lá o que
é do filme e que alguns momentos ele não
queria viver e ele acelerava e alguns
momentos que ele queria que chegasse e
ele passava para aquele momento e às
vezes nós vivemos assim existe aqueles
momentos tristes que a gente não quer
viver que a gente quer acelerar mas a
gente tem que viver aquilo também ele
existe alguns momentos que são
maravilhosos que a gente quer viver a
gente não vê a hora de chegar aquilo e a
gente esquece da nossa jornada que a
jornada também é vida então ao invés de
querer viver apenas Momentos Especiais
Aproveite às vésperas também viva às
vésperas também Viva Mais Intensamente
cada momento
Ah e falando isso eu lembro de uma
história
é de uma história que eu vivi com o meu
irmão a gente ganhava presentes mas em
datas mais especiais como o natal e às
vezes um aniversário a gente ganhava um
presente e existe um certo Natal que o
meu irmão ganhou uma bola e ligou uma
bola de um time de futebol o time do
coração dele só que eu também queria
ganhar uma bola e quando ele ganhou
aquela bola eu fiquei feliz por ele mas
a minha expectativa era de também ganhar
uma bola só que isso não aconteceu e por
que não aconteceu porque quando eu vi a
embalagem do meu presente ele era
quadrado então se não fosse uma bola
Quadrada
e eu deduzi que não poderia ser uma bola
mas a minha mente talvez passou que
poderia ser uma outra coisa quem sabe
uma chuteira temos uma bola e uma
chuteira e a felicidade e ela chegaria
para nós só que não é uma chuteira era
um carrinho boiadeiro um carrinho com
vários boizinhos de plástico e eu olhei
para aquilo e descer eu não tô feliz com
isso eu não queria isso eu queria uma
bola também só que aquela bola que meu
irmão ganhou a gente começou a jogar
brincar e o carrinho que eu ganhei a
gente também começou a brincar
e talvez você vai querer uma bola e a
vida vai te entregar um carrinho talvez
você vai querer viver só momento feliz
mas a vida vai te entregar alguns
momentos que são um pouco mais tristes
só que tudo é vida todo momento é vida
todo segundo é vida então Não esperem
momento perfeito não espere a
oportunidade perfeita mais faça o
momento perfeito faça oportunidade o
Prefeito Não existe Dias especiais
porque todos os dias são especiais para
aqueles que sabem viver a vida às vezes
vai te entregar um carrinho e o que você
tá fazendo com as dificuldades que a
vida tá Te Entregando e eu faço uma
reflexão para a gente encerrar esse
momento e é uma grande reflexão
e eu queria falar sobre esse trem que
você está vendo na imagem a nossa vida é
como se fosse um trem nós estamos lá
dentro observando a paisagem passar e
talvez a qualidade da nossa viagem não
está na velocidade mas o quanto a gente
consegue aproveitar a paisagem a nossa
vida também pode ser comparada a fumaça
que sai desse trem que logo você percebe
mas logo ela some e a gente não se dá
mais conta a nossa vida é como se fosse
um presente o presente que está na mão
dessa menina cabe você aceitar viver
esse presente intensamente ou você
deixar a vida passar e perceber que
perdeu uma grande oportunidade uma
oportunidade de viver quando a sua vida
já está no fim e o que é refletir sobre
essa Neve também porque essa Neve muitas
vezes para algumas pessoas podem
representar felicidade e para outras não
porque tem
em dias de sol e tem dias e tem pessoas
que gostam de dias mais nublados só que
quem aprende a viver esse fosse o seu
último dia pode ter certeza você não se
importaria se estivesse chovendo sol ou
se tivesse fazendo Neve você apenas
viveria e intensamente e sabe mais uma
coisa você queria que aqueles momentos
fossem eternos você gostaria de segurar
o relógio senão não vai não passa tempo
fica porque eu quero aproveitar um
pouquinho mais a vida as pessoas que eu
amo e para encerrar eu quero terminar
com uma frase de Ana Vilela que a vida é
trem-bala parceiro e a gente é só
passageiro prestes a partir a vida tá
passando os momentos estão passando e eu
espero que você aproveite e viva com
intensidade a sua vida muito obrigado a
todos paz e prosperidade
[Aplausos]
[Música]
E aí